as you were talking about the cosmic
perspective we do like to ask a couple
questions on the show do you think we
are alone in the cosmos have you guys
heard of the trance engine hypothesis no
okay
let's play this so it's a good theory to
account for Fermi's paradox Fermi's
paradox is the one that says that given
the size of the universe of even the
observable universe and given the
preconditions that potentially are there
for life how come we see no evidence of
intelligent life right we found all
these earth-like planets all these
things in the habitable zone and then
you just infer the rest using some
mathematical equations about scale and
you're like wow there there should be
plenty of advanced civilizations and yet
we see no evidence of it that's Fermi's
paradox right there should be but there
isn't and so the transection hypothesis
is an answer to that paradox and
basically it says the following if you
look at our own evolution and our
technological advancement it goes in two
directions it goes outward as we spread
across the planet and make massive
cities and make airplanes and then make
rockets and go to the moon like there's
this outward expansion of our
technological scaffolding right like a
spider's web like spreading out
potentially into the universe yet
simultaneously there's this inward
expansion as we make denser and denser
computational substrates right the chips
keep getting more powerful the
processing capacity gets more powerful
and infinitely smaller until you
eventually might get to what he calls
femto scale computing which is computing
that's thing computational density
that's on the on the size of it looks
like black hole like dimensions of
computational density okay and the idea
being is we have this outward expansion
but then we have this much faster
exponential inward expansion and no
doubt eventually maybe a couple hundred
years whatever we're gonna live in
virtual realities because that's just
what gonna happen synthetic artificial
and
that can sink and essentially have
personhood will live inside of these
virtual realms inside of femto scale
density computational substrates so
we're gonna basically open up a virtual
universe that's operating in dimensions
that are smaller than the more dense
than a black hole so we will disappear
out of space and time out of the visible
universe through these scale data and
and so transection is basically that we
like we disappear into into an outside
of space and time and that's when we
find all the other advanced
civilizations so they they went in
instead of out mm-hmm that's transection
that's a real thing coined by a guy
called John smart you can google it I
made a video about why we don't why we
don't we haven't found the aliens I
certainly don't believe any of the
reports of flying saucers or anything
like that don't sound more like
psychedelic delusions that's a really
good one though transaction hypothesis
that's a really interesting okay and
then do you think we're already in the
simulation I'm gonna read a passage to
answer that on Latian hypothesis like
whether we're in a simulation right now
like I just think it can be argued
either way but one of the things that um
you just argued for transition
hypothesis yeah yeah but but listen to
this so um Kevin Kelley talks about he
started Wired magazine he talks about a
series of discontinuities that have
changed how we see ourselves in the
cosmos the first one was when we thought
we were the center of the universe and
then we realized we're just a little
speck of dust in the sunbeam and then
and then another discontinuity has been
the one that we think that we're like
somehow special and the other
are not like the odds and they're not
and then we realized evolution though
we're the same we're on a continuity so
the discontinuity was was illuminated
again the third one that we're going
through now is that we think ourselves
as different from the man-made or the
human-made so there's the natural the
organic and the human-made is somehow
unnatural but increasingly we realized
that we're just smack in the middle
between the born and the made and that's
another continuum in the Technium which
is the Kevin Kelly phrase for the
organism that we call technology he
calls the seventh kingdom of life so
technologies we realize is just
continuous with biological evolution but
then the last exceptionalism and it goes
into this idea of whether we're in a
situation or not the fifth discontinuity
is the special status that we give to
the physical we feel the universe to be
a place physical material that pushes
back and presses and presses against us
things have weight size and duration
that's what the universe is an everyday
experience the real stuff that can be
measured felt and sensed our world of
matter and energy follows a set of laws
to such an exacting degree that we can
manipulate it to make rockets and
computers that's pretty solid matters
consistent refusal to be bullied outside
of its own laws adds to the sense of it
being real right real means physical
right information on the other hand
lacks physicality unlike energy which we
can at least measure with physical
instruments a digital bit is disembodied
it weighs nothing it takes up no space
we don't have good measures for
information we are not yet sure if the
total amount of information in the
universe is conserved nor if it is
finite yet we have come to see that life
even our own life is a pattern of
intangible information rather than
material form evolution that great
engine of creation is a pattern of
information and mind especially the mind
is a type of information flow so we know
that the most powerful forces in the
universe that we are aware of are
constructed of the most
tangible things we can detect bits there
stands the discontinuity Adams versus
bits but lately physicists have become
to suspect that atoms themselves are
composed of information in some way that
we don't understand as the legendary
physicist John Wheeler puts it it's our
bits the deeper we inspect the interior
of subatomic particles and their quirky
behavior the more they can be explained
as information flows many physicists
expect that when we get to the bottom of
how matter works
we'll find primarily a structure of
information and the absence of anything
material atoms will be understood as
elaborate dynamic arrangements of
intangible signals solid-state physicist
David Merman writes matter acts but
there are no actors behind the actions
the verbs are verbing all by themselves
without a need to introduce nouns
actions act upon other actions
there's no duality between the existence
of a thing and its properties properties
are all there is indeed there are no
things as this discontinuity between the
realm of the physical and the realm of
the immaterial is erased
scientists have began to re-envision the
laws of physics as complex algorithms of
code energy also is being restated in
terms of information the pulsating stars
and iron planets will gradually be seen
by science as wisps of intangible
nothings organisms and technologies
including mega structures like
skyscrapers and starships and floating
cities will be defined as structures of
computation equivalent to software so if
that's the case yeah then yeah yeah
really happy that you read that Jason
last question and we'll open up for Q&A
last question is what he thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world
whoo so I recently uh I underwent an
experience of psycholytic therapy which
is with a nurse who has a degree in
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy to
take care of me
to address some related issues that I
had with anxiety you know I deal and one
of the things that I that came to mind
during that time was that the most not
just when something is beautiful but the
sensation that it occasions right the
feeling of beholding beauty right is the
most exquisite and important thing in
the world and by the way that's a big
umbrella term you can include love under
Beauty you can including aesthetic
experiences under Beauty but but I just
think that to me the most beautiful
thing in the world is the cognitive and
aesthetic orgasm which is the moment in
which you commune with something
magnificent beyond yourself so it's a
moment of revealed truth and ecstasy and
merger and communion and it's when you
cry not from sadness but from ecstasy
right
why does beauty make us cry ask Alain de
Botton and he says it's because what it
hints at is the exception and so there's
this cognitive dissonance between what
you're seeing and what you know the
average to be and in order to correct
that imbalance you cry it fixes the the
discontinuity there and that's called
catharsis I love catharsis
you know but but you know you can be you
can have an experience like watching a
film and a film builds up slowly and
magnificently or a melody might do and
you know it works - have you heard
Jordan Peterson talk about music and how
it speaks meaning to people it's the one
thing that cynical people can't be
cynical about and I feel the same way
about about good films you know they're
they speak meaning they broadcast
meaning you know and and you know we're
meaning is like oxygen for us you guys
know that line that says you know human
being can live for you know a week
without food or three or four days
without water but I can't live for a
minute without hope right commit suicide
when they lose hope meaning is the
antidote to hopelessness meaning and
significant you know is everything and
and so the capacity of music and cinema
to do the way it delivers meaning to us
the way it patterns it you know like
like melodically and then like spoon
feeds it to us you know is almost
tantric in a cognitive way you know it's
it's it's to me it's everything and and
and to regularly submit you know talk
about surrender the ecstatic surrender
to a work of art to a work of meaning I
think is the the greatest possible
indulgence that we can give ourselves
amidst the cosmic tragedy of being
finite beings who dream of immortality
so that's like the temporary fix until
the singularity makes us all immortal
and saves us so yeah what a wonderful
conversation Jason just super blessed
I've had you in San Francisco I've been
here we all greatly appreciate you and
love your work so much and we hope to
hope to see you again very soon thanks
bro thank you
take some question you an a now